I am greeting you in the name of our
Lord Jesus we're going to be delighted
studying together God's word during your
program the 3abn Bible Q&A program this
hour is so special it's special for us
ESP special for many of our viewers who
have sent in their questions and their
comments I'm greeting you my name is
Evalia deny and we have our panelists
who have received your questions and
have prepared themselves to um share
with you what the Bible says so we're
going to learn during this hour this is
the best class in planet Earth so I'm
glad you're tuned in so welcome you all
from home and I'd like to welcome James
Raff who is uh tuning in digitally
virtually this is amazing welcome Pastor
rafy it's great technology I'm all the
way from the West Coast but it is great
to be here with you idalia and with
pastor morone and Professor Daniel amen
amen looking forward to the blessing we
have from the Lord this hour Pastor
Daniel Moroni welcome well thank you I'm
all the way here from West Frankfurt I'm
enjoying the weather out here today and
I'm just thankful for these uh questions
that we have and always enjoy the
questions and be able to answer from the
Bible amen amen and we have Daniel
pering with us welcome glad to be here
I'm all the way from three miles down
the road but you know every time we get
these questions sometimes it's the same
questions but everybody asks them in a
little bit of a different way that
prompts you to to look at it in another
way in another way well you know what
Jesus is the way I want to share with
you something uh from scripture and this
is um in Proverbs number chapter 2 my
son if you receive my words and treasure
my commands with you so that you incline
your ear to wisdom and apply your heart
to understanding yes if you cry out for
discernment and lift up your voice for
understanding if you seek her as silver
and search for her as for Hidden
Treasures then you will understand the
fear of the Lord and find the knowledge
of God for the Lord gives wisdom for his
mouth come knowledge and understanding
so praise God we are going to the Lord
in prayer to ask for that wisdom and
understanding of his word and I'm gonna
ask Pastor if you don't mind
praying for us here and our viewers at
home too all
right Father in Heaven Lord what a
privilege it is to come to you the god
of the whole universe the one who knows
all and Lord we thank you for providing
us your word that we can gain wisdom and
knowledge from you yes through your holy
spirit so we're inviting your Holy
Spirit to be with those that are viewing
listen listening and being with us
father that your Holy Spirit would speak
to us and then through Us in Jesus
precious name amen amen amen amen amen
thank you well I want to encourage you
to stay tuned don't change the channel
don't walk away take the phone with you
you can listen to the program praise the
Lord and also I'm going to encourage you
to uh share this program in your social
media platforms so that others who have
questions like the ones we're going to
be tending to during this hour can also
listen to those answers but for you who
are saying oh my question I forgot to
send it in well the email where you can
send in your questions is Bible QA 3abn
TV Bible QA 3abn.org
and you can send your comments and your
questions through text and the number to
send your text is 618 228
3975 618 228
3975 all right students it's class time
ready well we're going to go to pastor
rafy and this question came through an
email and this is the question it says
can you please explain 1 Peter 3:18 and
19 what SP spirits that Jes Jesus
preached to I don't understand
it there's been considerable
misunderstanding about these texts and I
remember when I was in Pakistan doing
evangelism in the 1990s a Methodist
Pastor who was coming to the Adventist
Faith actually shared with me from his
erdu Bible these texts and it actually
included the word Purgatory their
translation taught that Christ had
descended to some place called Purgatory
to preach to lost souls who were in
limbo now this is not what the text is
actually saying and the best way to
understand this text is to break it down
Point by point and we're going to do
that beginning with Verse 18 but we're
also going to include verse 20 which our
questioner didn't include in his
question but we're going to include that
verse because it will help for
clarification Verse 18 says for Christ
also both suffered for us for our sins
the just for the unjust that he might
bring us to God being put to death in
the flesh but quickened by the spirit I
love that beautiful gospel flavor right
there by which which also he went and
preached now let's stop there for a bit
first we want to notice how Christ
preached to those Spirits in prison
because in this verse verse 19 it said
it was by which he also preached he did
it by the spirit and that word that that
letter of that word is capitalized in
the Bible Spirit has a capital s that
means it's referring to the holy spirit
so whatever Christ did in preaching
during this time he did it through the
Holy Spirit now let's ask the question
when was the preaching done and we want
to let the verse answer it for us so
we'll go to verse 20 when Once the
longsuffering of God waited in the days
of Noah while the ark Was preparing
wherein few that is in eight Souls were
saved that's verse 20 we've included
that verse to help answer the question
and unlock the puzzle when was the
preaching done it was done during the
anti deluvian age during the time when
the ark was being built and Noah was
preaching and he was preaching to the
anti- delians the delians refer to the
Deluge of water so anti is before the
Deluge of water and then it goes on to
say um that he was preaching through the
Holy Spirit now one more question we
want to ask is this to whom was he
preaching the text says to those who
were imprison and this is the most
difficult part of the whole point in
these verses 18-2 the whole section and
that is he was preaching unto Spirits in
prison which were sometime disobedient
now throughout the Bible we find this
terminology used to describe those who
are bound in the prison House of sin
David actually prayed bring my soul out
of prison that I may praise thy name and
that's found in Psalm 142:7 Jesus says
in Luke 4:8 the spirit of the Lord is be
upon me because he has anointed me to
preach or proclaim the good news to the
poor he has sent me to Proclaim freedom
for the prisoners and recovery of the of
sight for the Blind and to set the
oppressed free that's Luke 4:18 and
that's the an NIV version Isaiah 426
and7 says I the Lord have called thee in
righteousness and I will hold thy hand I
will keep Thee I will give thee for a
covenant of Peace for a light to the
Gentiles to open the blind eyes and
bring the prisoners out of prison and
them that sit in darkness out of the
prison house Isaiah 426 and 7 so the
Apostle Paul even describes this
experience in his words he says that
that sin was bringing me into captivity
right Romans
7:4 and just a few verses later he says
how he was made free from this prison
House of captivity by the spirit or the
Holy Spirit by the power of the Holy
Spirit and that's Romans 8 veres 1 and 2
so everything's in harmony with what the
Bible says the Bible is simply saying
that Christ through the Holy Spirit was
present while they preached Christ was
there through the Holy Spirit to speak
conviction to the hearts and appeal to
those who were in the prison House of
sin and that this is a Biblical teaching
that that those Souls who are sinning
are in a prison House of sin so there
are three questions that are clearly
answered in the text itself that he
preached by the holy spirit that he did
it while the ark was being prepared and
that he did it to the spirits and prison
through the Holy Spirit to the spirits
in prison during the anti- deluvian Age
who abound in the prison House of sin I
hope that answers your question amen
thank you very much Pastor rery right
now we're going to go to Pastor Moroni
and we have this text that we received
from North aota Jerry took the time to
send in this question and we want to
thank you for participating and it says
is once saved always saved
biblical good question Jerry thank you
for your question amen that's a age-old
question isn't it a lot of people
wondered that I I have a few texts that
I want to share that kind of shows the
opposite that it's once we're saved
we're not always saved all right so
here's one in second Peter 2: 20 to 22
says for if after they have escaped the
pollutions of the the world through the
knowledge of the Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ they are again entangled therein
and overcome the latter end is worse
with them than the beginning for it had
been better for them not to have known
the way of righteousness then after they
have known it to turn from the holy
commandment delivered unto them but it
is happened unto them according to the
true proverb the dog is turned to his
own vomit again and the s or the female
pig that was washed to her wallowing in
the
mire so this text is quite explanatory
and it's quite graphic also have you
ever seen a dog
vomit get all of that putrid substance
out of their stomach then turn around
and Chow Down On It doesn't sound good
nope or a cute little pig all washed
nice and clean turn around and jump into
the mud and mire rubbing it body in the
Slime so that you can't even tell that
it was
washed so that's
what's anyway it's very interesting how
the Bible correlates that so it sounds
like we can go back into sin 1
Corinthians chapter 10:12 wherefore let
him that thinketh standeth think that he
stands take heed lest he fall that was a
pretty obvious one there we don't want
to be careless in our thinking because
we can fall from God's grace here's 1
John 1:7 but if we walk in the light as
he is in the light we have Fellowship
one with another and the blood of Jesus
Christ his son cleanses us from all sin
if if is a little word but it's got a
big meaning so after the scriptures to
these are some other scriptures that you
can write them down uh Galatians 5:4
Hebrews 3:12 James 5:19 but I want to go
to the Old Testament here Jeremiah 18 8
to10 if that Nation against whom I have
pronounced turn from their evil and will
repent of the evil that I thought to do
them and at what instant I shall speak
concerning a nation and concerning a
kingdom to build to plant it if it do
evil in my sight that it obey not my
voice then I will repent of the good
wherewith I said I would benefit them
and one last one when I this is in
Ezekiel 33:13 when I shall say to the
righteous that he shall surely live if
he trusts to his own righteousness and
commit iniquity all all his
righteousness shall not be remembered
but for his iniquity that he hath
committed he will die for it it sounds
like we can lose our Salvation or not
once saved always saved anyway amen
thank you so much Pastor moriconi we're
moving on to Daniel ping and we received
this um next text from uh Anthony who is
in Canada can you please explain John
8817 and 18
two witnesses are not always true naath
had two witnesses andony wants to know
all right so you're referring to John 8
here in John 8 verse 13 the Pharisees
are saying to Jesus you're witness you
can't witness for yourself there has to
be another witness and so Jesus says in
verse 15 he says you judge according to
the Flesh in other words your witness is
not reliable but then he says my w my
judgment is true verse 16 and then we
get to verse 17 that you asked about so
then Jesus referring to the Old
Testament that talks about witnesses
that are used to condemn somebody who is
an accused criminal he says it is also
written in your law that the testimony
of two men is true I am one who Bears
witness of myself and the father who
sent me Bears witness of me so the
testimony of Jesus and the testimony of
the father certainly is true but we
can't always trust human beings because
we don't always tell the truth so this
text here is referring back to an Old
Testament statement I'll get to in a
moment that is about establishing truth
in a conflict where you need Witnesses
and in human fa Affairs the witness
could literally hold the life of someone
in their hands literally they could be
put to death because of a lying witness
or at least their reputation could be
destroyed and this is why God gives us
the ninth commandment you shall not bear
false witness against your neighbor and
he tells us in Proverbs 12 lying lips
are an abom ation to the Lord why be
true because God is true and Truth mercy
and Truth go before him righteousness
and Justice are the foundation of his
throne Psalm
89:14 so God cares about humans and he
cares about their lives and so here's
what he says in Deuteronomy 17:6 whoever
is deserving of Death Shall be put to
death on the testimony of two or three
Witnesses you shall not be put to death
on the testimony of one witness now the
text doesn't say here that the witness
will never lie but it says that you
can't condemn on the basis of less than
two witnesses why is that because two
witnesses uh two witnesses could
certainly conspire but it makes it more
difficult for them to do so you you
can't accidentally conspire as a false
with a false witness your stories might
not add up under scrutiny or or the
truth might come out someone's demeanor
reveals the deception but uh when when
humans are involved uh in order to to
keep the truth from being hidden in
order to bring the truth to light God
says two or three Witnesses and then
Proverbs 19:9 says a false witness will
not go unpunished and he who speaks lies
Shall Perish now Jesus is the only true
witness and that's why uh in the Book of
Revelation he is referred to Revelation
3:14 as the true witness his testimony
will never lie and his witness is
corroborated his witness of himself is
corroborated by that of the father who
we also are told in the Bible cannot lie
amen praise the Lord wow well I want to
thank Ismael from Florida who sent in
the next um question through email and
this is what it says and Pastor rafy
please answer how can we explain Hebrews
9:12 in regards to
1844 and the Heavenly Sanctuary it
mentions that Christ has already entered
a Most Holy
Place good question Ismael thank you for
sending that in there at least three
ways we can explain this text one is the
immediate context of Hebrews the other
is the original Greek meaning of the
words and then the larger context of the
Bible so you're going to find that start
with the first one the immediate context
of Hebrews that Paul in the book of
Hebrews is not concerned with the Holy
place and the most holy place of the
sanctuary whether it's a Earthly
Sanctuary or a Heavenly sanctuary in
Hebrews 9 he begins by explaining the
most the holy place and the most holy
place of the Earthly Sanctuary he's
already said that in Hebrews 8 that the
Earthly Sanctuary was a type of the
Heavenly sanctuary and now it explains
in detail the articles that are in the
Holy place and the most holy place in
fact in Hebrews 9 in verses 1-5 that is
the only place where we ever find the
Greek word hagon hagon which fitly
describes the most holy place of the
Heavenly Sanctuary that phrase hagon
hagon is never used again in the book of
Hebrews and so we can conclude that Paul
never again talks about the most holy
place in fact he even says that in the
context he says we don't really have
time to talk about the most holy place
we need to get on to other things we
can't speak spec uh particularly of this
right now or in detail of this right now
in Hebrews 9 and verse 5 so right there
we find evidence that anywhere else in
Hebrews specifically in verse 12 if you
as you've mentioned there is no he is
not talking about the most holy place
that's one way we know that because Hag
on hag on is how the most holy place is
described and it's those words are not
used in verse 12 we also know from
translations because the translation of
the NIV and the new KJV are the are are
different from the translations of the
KJV and ASV and and other translations
of the Bible the other translations
simply say the holy place or the holy
places but they're not really referring
to the most holy place the only way that
this can be understood that is Paul can
be understood to be talking about the
holiest is when he's transitioning from
the Earthly to the Heavenly not from the
holy place to the most holy place that's
his point Paul is seeking to transition
the Hebrews from the Earthly Sanctuary
to the Heavenly Sanctuary from the
Earthly type to the Heavenly reality and
the Heavenly reality in his mind is the
holiest he's not actually referring to
the most holy place of the Heavenly
Sanctuary but to the holiest in
reference to the Earthly so the large
context of the Bible also tells us that
the priest which was a type of Christ
began his ministry in the Holy place and
then on the day of attonement he moved
to the most holy place and a detailed
study of Daniel 8:14 with Daniel chap 9:
24 to 27 will tell us that Jesus
transitioned from the holy place to the
mo Most Holy place in 1844 we also know
it from the sanctuary symbolism in The
Bible because in the Book of Revelation
Revelations churches seals and trumpets
all begin in John's day and they all
begin with a picture of Christ in the
with the furniture of the Holy place and
not the most holy place of the sanctuary
amen amen thank you so much we continue
with the next question and uh I want to
thank is SM from Florida for sending
that that question through email but now
we move on to the state of Illinois we
received an email from Curtis Curtis
thank you for your participation to it
says Jacob in parenthesis uh Israel had
12 sons thus making the 12 tribes of
Israel one Reuben two Simeon Levi Judah
Dan Neftali God Asher
isachar Saum Joseph Benjamin but the 12
tribes the 144,000 in Revelation 7 4-8
are Judah Reuben God Asher
neali manasse Simeon Levi isachar sealon
Joseph and Benjamin why is Dan omitted
and manasse added and why manasse and
not Ephraim thank you Curtis W clarify
that Pastor all right thank you
Curtis I think they just wanted you to
pronounce all of those I hope I passed
the test you did a good job fantastic
yes thank you Curtis Curtis yeah that's
a good question it's a deep question
actually thoughtful question I never
actually thought about it before I've
read through it but never even paid
attention but that's really good you're
very keen Bible student out there you
know the Old Testament and I went to
commentaries to get this answer here so
these are the theologians to give you
this answer the okay Old Testament lists
commonly you know these lists that the
Old Testament goes through usually begin
with Ruben because he was the oldest of
Jacob's
children uh whereas here in Revelation
it begins with Judah and perhaps it was
because Christ came from the tribe of
Judah you look at that up in Revelation
55 well in the Old Testament Levi is
sometimes not included in as a tribe it
was doubtless because they didn't get
any land inheritance the tribe of Levi
they were the priests and so they didn't
they had cities rather than property
that they lived in and that's in Joshua
chapter
13:14 well here the tribe of Levi is
actually counted in Revelation and yet
Dan like you mentioned is
omitted and to include Levi and yet
maintain the number 12 One Tribe had to
be omitted since Joseph was considered
as two tribes namely Ephraim and
Manasseh and uh the word
um Joseph here when you were asking that
question why Ephraim versus Manasseh the
word Joseph actually is standing for
Ephraim that was another uh word or name
that they used instead of Ephraim they
would say Joseph so I'll show you that
in numbers chap 1: 32 and 33 says of the
children of Joseph namely the children
of Ephraim by their Generations after
their families by the house of their
fathers according to the number of the
names from 20 years old and upward all
that were able to go forth to war those
that were numbered of the tribe of
Ephraim were
40,500 so that's how you get you know
you're were wondering what why Ephraim
was mentioned vers of Manasseh but they
use the word Joseph for Ephraim all
right and perhaps Dan is excluded
because of that tribe's idolatry the
reputation of its idolatry that's found
in judges chap 18: 30 and 31 here's a
um quote from that the children of Dan
set up the Graven image and Jonathan the
son of gersam the son of Manasseh he and
his sons were priests to the tribe of J
Dan until the day of the Captivity of
the land and they set them up Michael's
Graven image which he made all the time
that the house of God was in Shiloh so I
hope that answers your question uh
Curtis that was a really good question
made me dig thank you so much excellent
excellent well he was also he is a sad
student too so he's studying all right
guys um Daniel Bing are you ready for
your next one ready all right well
Caesar want to make sure you get a
question asked and he Cesar is from
Florida he's sending a text and the
question is should
Christians
celebrate Mother's Day since it has
Pagan Roots all right you're wondering
what I'm going to say here yes well we
want to follow the instructions of God
rather than the traditions of man and
neither do we want to be led by
sentimentality but I have to say that
not all traditions of men necessarily go
against God's commands and neither does
do things that invite sentimentality so
here's what the Bible says you can find
this text in Exodus 20 or Deuteronomy 5
repeated again in Ephesians 6 honor your
father and your mother both of them that
the days your days may be long in the
land which the Lord your God is giving
you
yes but how how do we do that well uh
Mother's Day sorry mothers are deserving
of Honor I don't think any of us would
disagree with that if you do that's a
different issue altogether but uh
mothers really are deserving of Honor
but the Bible does not command us to set
aside a specific day for that purpose
neither does the bible prohibit us for
from participating in a day like that to
honor mothers so here is the principle
that we can find in Romans 14:5
one person esteems one day above another
another person esteems every day alike
Let each be fully convinced in his own
mind now the topic of Romans 14 is not
about Mother's Day but the principle
Still Remains without a Divine command
saying yes or no you should know why you
believe what you believe and why you do
what you do and have foundation for that
upon the word of God from the principles
in God's word so much of it depends
really upon on how and why you celebrate
the how would be your actual activities
and the why would be your motivation so
let me give you a couple of questions
here that you might find useful in
evaluating the how and the why of
Mother's Day in your own life number one
what is the purpose of your celebration
are you placing human loyalties above
the loyalty to God what is the result of
your celebration will your actions
glorify God or glorify people will your
celebration wisely use the resources God
has given will your actions cause
someone else to stumble in their faith
does your mother appreciate your
kindness on Mother's Day and would
ignoring the day send her a message of
disrespect Psalm 127:3 says children are
a reward can your mother honestly say
that the way you treat her is a reward
for what she sacrificed for you are you
honoring your mother temporarily out of
a sense of Duty only or do you have
genuine gratitude that is present in
your interaction every day are you
convicted that saying thank you to your
mother on the second Sunday of May is
participating in Pagan worship rituals
right that's that's your conviction
would the typical activities of Mother's
Day be suitable on another day of the
month flowers cards thank yous phone
calls helping her well if those are
suitable anytime then the issue that we
might be struggling with some might be
struggling with is this particular day
only and then one two more questions
here is it wrong to affirm and
participate with the good things that
non-believers do I'm not answering these
I'm putting them out there for you to
direct your thinking here and finally
what has God indicated to you in your
prayer and bible study time I would ask
you and direct you to review these these
statements here Proverbs 31: 25 to 30
this is talking about a Godly woman here
and the hon Oro her through God
Deuteronomy 6: 6 and 7 talking about
parents as teachers 2 Timothy 1:5
talking about The Godly influence of of
mothers who have committed their lives
to God and 1 Peter 3 and 4 talking about
the character of a Godly woman or mother
and so after you've reviewed those honor
God by appreciating your mother for the
sacrifices the labor the teaching the
wisdom the godliness and don't wait for
someone of the world to give you
permission and tell you what day to do
it on uh don't let them tell you when
how and why ask the Lord say Lord how
can I honor uh the parents that you've
placed in my life thank you Mom thank
you Mom amen and amen amen and thank you
Jesus for our moms all right guys um
it's time to share the contact
information because um I'm sure these
are triggering or Awakening some of your
doubts and questions so you can send
them via email Bible QA
3abn.org
3abn _ official and you can send your
text to the number 618 228
3975 618 228
3975 I am enjoying these questions
praise the Lord and um I just want to
encourage you all to participate this is
your class now Pastor rafy Revelation
1:7 says behold he is coming with clouds
in every eye shall see him even those
who pierced him will everyone see Jesus
at the same time upon his return Grace
from Maryland wants to
know well Grace that is a great question
a good question that's one that I have
thought on and wondered about myself so
I'm I'm glad that you shared that
question uh let's let let's take a look
at what the Bible says uh in Matthew
chapter 24 and verse 27 Matthew chapter
24 and verse 27 and then we'll continue
to read verses 30 and 31 Matthew 24:27
says for as Lightning comes out of the
East and shines even under the West so
also shall the coming of the son of man
be and then it goes on to say this then
will appear in heaven the sign of the
son of man and then all the tribes of
the Earth shall mourn they shall see the
son of man coming on the Clouds Of
Heaven with power and great glory and he
will send his angels with a great
trumpet call with a loud trumpet call
and they will gather his elect from the
Four Winds from one end of the Earth to
the other so it's pretty clear here that
Jesus when he comes everyone's going to
see him now the question you're asking
is is everyone going to see him at the
same time I don't think so the way I
would illustrate this is it would be
like the sun is seen as the Earth
circles it each day everyone sees the
sun within a 24-hour period so Jesus
will be seen by everyone on planet Earth
why because he's coming out of the East
he's going to the west but the time
frame for Jesus being seen it's going to
be a lot faster than 24 hours how do we
know that because Jesus says it's going
to be like lightning and you know how
lightning is if you've ever seen the sky
lit up with lightning as soon as you see
that lightning bright up it goes It goes
flying across the sky from one end to
the other so we're going to see Jesus
come from the East to the west but it's
going to be like lightning it's going to
be fast everyone's going to see him but
I'm not sure that everyone's going to
see him all all at the same time the day
he returns every eye will see him and in
the amount of time that he everyone sees
him we're not sure we're not sure how
long it's going to take for everyone to
see him but everyone's going to see him
on the day he returns and he's going to
gather his elect from one end of the
Earth to the other so some of us some of
the elect may be gathered or may rise a
little sooner than somebody else as we
see him as we hear the trumpet but it's
going to be very fast just like
lightning okay amen thank you very much
all right we need to move on to the next
question I do want to thank um Grace
from Maryland for sending in that text
uh Pastor moriconi I have this question
that came in from Jamaica in in the form
of email I want to become a better
student of the word that's my desire to
are there any tools or Aids you could
suggest such as Condor
concordances that would be of help to me
in achieving
this great question whoever you are from
Jamaica I don't know what your resources
you have but there's a you know as far
as the internet and so forth but here's
a a picture of some of the U resources
that you can get and I appreciate the
camera look at that you can see them all
in there yes but they've got the strong
exhaustive concordance and then there's
the Young's analytical concordance then
you've got uh Bible dictionaries or and
then some of them are done with um
expository Bible dictionary and you've
got encyclopedias or you've got a
parallel Bible a Bible that has
different uh translations in it you can
use all of those things and of course
online now they so they kind of makes
these kind of obsolete anymore these
books but uh there's the U uh Bible
Gateway maybe you've already use that I
don't know like I said if you have
access to the internet or not and then
also the Bible Hub is another one that
has all of these resources or a lot of
them on there then there's the software
too Bible Software like logos uh there's
other softwares out there but um you
know as far as since this was such a
quick question I thought well I'll show
you how to use like this is the anger's
Bible dictionary or here's the uh Vines
expository dictionary and so here if you
going to look up just a word here let's
say bride or brid room so it shows you
here like a regular dictionary it says
this term this is in the expository
dictionary this term is found just over
30 times in the Old Testament with the
Dual meanings daughter-in-law and spouse
or bride so the meaning bride attaches
to kala in half the context in which it
is found in song The Song of Solomon
like chapter 4: 8-5 the term refers six
times to The Newlywed bride or the lover
of overwhelming delight and passion so
that's just the regular or that's the
expository one and then here's one
that's just the Bible dictionary it's a
little different from the expository one
and I've got a couple plac marked for
that same word bride or it says
figuratively the church is alluded to
the Bride As the wife of the lamb and
meaning that it's the bridegroom
rejoices over the bride so then it's
actually as far as to look at it uh as
the same as this other one you it puts
it under marriage instead of the
figurative it says to go to the marriage
far as to see it as the bride in that
context so it says origin marriage is a
Divine institution designed to form a
permanent Union between man and woman
that they might be helpful to one
another so that's a just using the two
difference expository dictionary versus
just a regular Bible dictionary but
anyway you've got all kinds of resources
out there so I just commend you for
wanting to uh study and become more
proficient in Bible
amen amen and of course we have sad you
know School of discipleship right pastor
and we also have the three Aban Bible
study guides too right so that is also
aids for you well we continue on we move
along to Daniel pering we have the next
question and this one is from Andrew
thank you Andrew for taking the time and
sending in your question it says what
can we do to make worshiping the Lord a
pleasure all right um God has given us
Human Relationships as an illustration
of our relationship with him so let me
ask the question this way how can I make
spending time with my wife and talking
with her a pleasure what if I only talk
about things I enjoy that might make it
pleasurable well that's selfishness what
if I what if I smile a lot well that
that might be false maybe I what if I
just talk to her more maybe that could
change how I feel well really what I
need to do is focus on her character and
the beauty that God has placed within
her and my role as uh the servant and
the the the the leading servant in her
life the issue is if I enjoy my wife and
I love her characteristics and I love
her personality and our shared
experiences and her kindness and all
that is about her then I won't have to
try to have pleasure in the conversation
the time we spend together if I have to
try to enjoy the time I spend with my
wife then I either don't know her or I
don't love her one of those two worship
is enjoying God and who he is knowing
and Desiring him in Revelation 4: 9 to1
11 there are these 24 Elders who cast
down their their their crowns and and
they're they're constantly praising God
for who he is worshiping him for who he
is uh because if worship is not a
pleasure then it's not worship it's
bribery it's not from love but it's an
obligation worship is not simply
temporary actions like songs and giving
and and sacrifices and studying it's
simply the life that flows out of the
enjoyment of who God is it's how we live
it's the position that we take before
God honoring him so naturally we are
Rebels we don't want to worship God we
want to worship ourselves we want to go
our own way and do our own thing and so
to find pleasure in worship we need by
God's grace for two things to change the
first thing that need needs to change in
US is that we have to seek God for who
he is his infinite value and this is
where we begin studying the cross and
focusing on what Jesus did at the cross
Matthew 15:8 Jesus says these people
draw near to me with their mouth and
they honor me with their lips but their
heart is far from me they don't love me
truly love me and so we need to be drawn
to God drawn to him through Jesus and
what he's done Galatians 6:14 says God
forbid that I should boast except in the
Cross of the Lord Jesus Christ by whom
the world has been crucified to me and I
to the world see Jesus for who he is and
then what else needs to change is to see
our relationship our position before God
he is infinitely exalted and loving and
it is our pleasure to serve him to know
him to share him to to be conformed to
his likeness it's not simple or easy but
it is desirable and it is
enjoyable amen praise the Lord
wow it's a pleasure to to Worship the
Lord in spirit and in truth okay pastor
rafar we're going to you now and I want
to thank Gary from Oregon that sent in
an email since nearly all Bible prophecy
especially the great metal image is
largely related to events in the Middle
East is it reasonable to assume the
first and greatest end time events will
also Focus more intently on Middle East
conditions more and faster than the
other world continents and societies
Gary wants to
know thank you Gary my first response to
that question and Gary from Oregon where
we are from also we live there for many
years is assume nothing assume nothing
but it is true that the first part of
the Bible prophecy in Daniel 2 is
related to events that took place in
countries in the Middle East
but that does not mean that the Middle
East is still to this day the main focus
of Bible prophecy and it does not mean
that nearly all priv Bible prophecy is
largely related to events in the Middle
East we need to take a careful look at
Daniel chapter 2 and this great mental
image so that we can understand the
context of Bible prophecy and how it
relates to the Middle East today and I'm
going to take a little bit more time
with this question because I ended my
last question a little early so let's
start with Daniel chapter 2 the first
Power medal the head of uh gold Babylon
gone definitely in the Middle East me of
Persia gone definitely in the Middle
East Greece gone uh Greece is not
actually in the Middle East but they did
conquer a lot of the Middle East you're
you're finding here by the time you go
from Babylon and the Captivity of God's
people to the time of Greece and then
Imperial Rome you have a few hundred
years that have gone by Imperial Rome
comes on the stage uh well before Christ
comes and so you've got two thousand
years of this prophecy remaining at
least from the time of Christ until our
time only a few hundred years have gone
by with focus on the Middle East and
we've already moved out of the Middle
East Gary we've moved to Greece and now
we're Imperial Rome which is not in the
Middle East at all it's primarily in
Europe of course Imperial Rome is gone
and now we move to papal Rome it is
still with us and it's still in Europe
so now Bible prophecy is fixed in Europe
not the Middle East and it has been for
many hundreds of years and so now as we
move through Daniel's prophecies in
Daniel 2 Daniel 7 Daniel 8 Daniel 11 we
find that they are all repeat and
enlarge meaning that each prophetic
cycle gives us more information about
where we are in Bible prophecy and and
then when we get to the Book of
Revelation when we add that to the mix
we find a connection to Daniel 7's
prophecies in Revelation 13 we have the
lion of Babylon and the bear of me of
Persia and the leopard of Greece and and
then we have the dragon of Rome and the
10 horns representing the 10 St St of
Europe the 10 nations of Europe and then
we discover another Power with lamb
likee horns rising up out of the earth
not the sea and of course this power in
Revelation 13:11 represents the very
last movements of Prophecy and it comes
up in the earth which represents a less
inhabited part of the world so this does
not fit the middle east Europe history
does not fit the Middle East most of the
Prophecies of Daniel are not in the
Middle East at all most of the
prophecies a couple thousand years of
the Prophecies of of Daniel are actually
in Europe and then move over to this
Earth or the United States of America
United States of America is in Prophecy
in fact there are seven characteristics
of this second power in Revelation
chapter 13 and that identify it as the
United States of America and one key
characteristic is its ability to make
the entire world comply with the worship
of the first power or papal roome or
lose their economic access and
eventually life itself and we're kind of
under the shadow of that right now we're
recognizing in the world today that
there are powers that are seeking to
inhibit our access to economics we've
seen that happen in the country north of
us we've seen that happen in some states
here through this covid pandemic and of
course we know Bible prophecy tells us
this is going to happen all of this is
taking place in Europe and the United
States they're some of the main players
here and of course they're going to
influence the rest
of the world so I really appreciate your
question Gary it's a great question uh
but we need to recognize that these two
Powers the power of the papacy which is
in Europe and the US they are the ones
that are the focus of the final events
to be fulfilled in Revelation chapter 13
and most of the Prophecies of Daniel and
Revelation actually focus in Europe and
the United States amen thank you so much
pator rery we're moving on to the next
question and this is is the last
question for pastor Moroni and we thank
the person that sent the email with this
question what does Matthew 24:20 mean
why did Jesus tell them to pray that
their flight might not be in Winter or
on the Sabbath Day pastor Moroni great
question in Matthew chapter 24 beginning
with verses 1 and two and Jesus went out
and departed from the temple and his
disciples came to him for to show him
the buildings of the Temple they were
really impressed with the temple figured
everybody else would be they were really
proud of the temple so here Jesus kind
of bursts their bubble and says in verse
two see ye not all these things verily I
say unto you there shall not be left one
stone upon another and shall not be cast
down so the rest of the chapter has
Jesus giving signs to his disciples of
his second coming along with the signs
of the destruction of Jerusalem because
they thought for sure if the temple was
destroyed then that would be the end of
the world in Matthew 24: 19 and 20 we
read and woe unto them with child and to
them that give suck or nursing in those
days but pray ye that your flight be not
in the winter nor on the Sabbath day and
that's what you ask there here's in Luke
chapter 21 it has a similar uh it's
talking about the same thing and when ye
shall see Jerusalem comforted with
armies then know that the Desolation
thereof is nigh then let them which are
in Judea flee to the mountains and let
them which are in the midst of it depart
out and let not them that are in the
countries enter there into so Jesus is
very merciful there the Christian people
they were warned ahead of time when the
was Jerusalem was surrounded by the
Roman armies then that was a sign that
they were to flee and the Lord worked it
out where they were able to flee and uh
so it says it would be hardship if they
were pregnant or nursing children during
that time definitely not a comfortable
situation this would be the same as if
it was in the winter time you know Jesus
wouldn't want them to have to leave in
the winter time so he said to pray that
it's not that way and because they would
need a lot more clothing to stay warm
and then God set the Sabbath apart that
we might rest and reflect upon him at
his
creation and his creation running for
your life and uh would surely not be a
nice it wouldn't be the nice rest time
that you would have and by the way aside
note to this passage Jesus is seeing the
future and he's telling his closest
followers to pray that their flight not
be on the Sabbath so he knew that the
Sabbath would still be in effect you
know cuz it was 70 AD before uh this
Jalem was destroyed and again thank you
for and history tells us it was either
August or September when it was
destroyed so it wasn't in the Winter
thank you very much thank you Pastor
moriconi H perin it says here my dog was
just diagnosed with leukemia we're sorry
to hear that is it a sin to euthanize
him is there anything in the Bible that
says anything about this from
Philadelphia well thank you for sending
this text in and we share the sadness
because when we love pets and they are
suffering it's difficult and many of us
have been in this situation before
making these decisions and to help you
in this I want to share three biblical
principles the first one is that God
made the animals and he loves them and
he cares about them Genesis 1 veres 24
and 25 God makes all the living
creatures and he looks and he said this
is good he's are good Psalm 50: 10 and
11 says every beast of the forest is
mine the cattle on a thousand hills I
know all the birds of the mountains God
knows them Luke 12:6 Jesus saying are
not five sparrows sold for two copper
coins and not one of them is forgotten
before God he cares about the birds
Psalm 104 and I love this text talking
about the glories of all God's work even
includes the animals here and talks
about leviathon this giant creature and
it uses language of it playing in the
water Jonah 4:1 God doesn't even want
the cattle in the city of Nineveh to
have to die and then I think of First
Kings 17: 4 to6 where the Ravens bring
food to Elijah it says that they are
obeying the voice of God that God is
communicating with these animals God
cares about our pets but principle
number two is that animals are different
from people while some people are trying
to give personhood to animals personhood
status God's word does not do this they
do not have a higher reasoning ability
or a moral conscience as as man does
they they can reason from cause to
effect perhaps just a little bit and it
might just be a bare stimulus response
effect but uh they they are separate and
they're different even though they can
communicate just a little bit with us
but they're not the same as humans
principle number three is that God has
entrusted with us the role of caretaking
which includes decisions over the lives
of animals Genesis 1:26 says we are to
have dominion not unilateral Authority
but caring for the animals as God does
Proverbs 12:10 says a righteous man
cares for the life of his animals or
regards them in Exodus 21 an animal is
to be put to death here permission to
put an animal to death if it's causing
danger to others so we see that that uh
God gives permission on occasion to take
the life of an animal and in Genesis 9:2
God allows that even for food uh all
right or allowed it they're given into
your hand it says and then Luke
14:15 uh Jesus says which of you who has
an oxen or a donkey that falls into a
pit would not pull him out on the
Sabbath day and the text is dealing with
emergency situations here but the
principle sometimes is that the only way
to get your animal out of the pit it's
stuck in is to mer mercifully bring its
suffering to the end uh as far as the
conclusion of these principles it is not
good to allow your animals to suffer
when you can relieve their suffering
either e by healthful interventions or
by bringing their suffering peacefully
and painlessly to an end and God has
given us the authority to make this
decision when the animal is suffering
I've had to do this it's a difficult
decision but you can do it without guilt
amen amen I want to thank you all thank
you for um still watching and paying
attention to these answers if you have
questions or even doubts just write to
us we're going to share some contact
information and we will be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible Q&A
then tell your friends each Monday we'll
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bible
QA 3abn.org
[Music]
618 228
3975 that's 618 228
3975 be sure to include your name and
where you live and then watch three Aban
Bible Q&A for answers from God's
word all right folks thank you for
standing by we're going to just um share
our last thoughts but I'd like to start
with James rafy Pastor rafy please share
from I just wanted to encourage Gary I
don't know if he's aware of our series
on Daniel Revelation called salvation in
symbols and signs which you can watch on
demand on a Dar to dream Channel with
the 3an Plus app and in there we go into
more detail about these prophecies and
their application and just connecting
them again with our question about
Christ in the most holy place when you
look in Revelation chapter 1 you see
Christ among the candle sticks now he's
been resurrected in Revelation 4 he's
again seen in the vision of the
candlesticks both of those Visions
direct us to the holy place of the
Heavenly sanctuary in Revelation 8 as
the trumpets began he's seen ministering
by the golden sensor or the golden altar
which was again in the Holy place of the
Earthly Sanctuary so Revelations
prophetic Cycles the churches the seals
and the trumpets all take us to this
picture of Christ in the Holy place so
that confirms what Hebrews is telling us
with the King James version some of
these other versions Christ didn't go
into the most holy place he went into
the holy Place study more about this in
Salvation and simps and signs amen and
praise the Lord for that app 3abn plus
all that material is available praise
the Lord for that well Pastor moriconi
what worse would you like to share with
our viewers well that one question that
someone asked about the uh why did Jesus
pray that their flight be not in the
winter on the Sabbath it just brings out
the compassion that God has has for us
as his people just want to share that
instructions in everything praise the
Lord okay pastor pering what do we have
yes Mother's Day Father's Day
Grandparents Day any other days for
loved ones don't put off till later what
you could do to appreciate someone right
now so Mom if you're watching Dad if
you're watching grandparents if you're
watching I love you I appreciate you and
I don't want to wait until later one
more principle from that same Book of
Romans chapter 14 it deals with those
who disagree with you if if somebody's
convictions on Mother's Day or any other
day like that is different from yours
don't judge them don't disdain them just
you do what is what you believe to be
right from God's word and and stand up
on that amen amen well I believe class
is adjourned okay so folks thank you for
tuning in don't forget to send in your
questions and your comments it's been a
pleasure God bless you see you next time
[Music]